world all street fighter fans video
gaming fans
we got news for you guys and i promise
you you don't want to miss it
my name is tasty steve and i'm joined by
none other
than the bald eagle of commentary
vicious bro how is it going man
it's going pretty well man i've been
looking forward to the summer update for
quite some time you know we've been
going through
a lot of the capcom pro tour we've had a
lot of events for street fighter 5 and
to be quite honest with you
what better way to kick off this half of
the air then with nothing but
complete surprises right this summer
update just like the spring one
we're going into it completely
blindfolded as
are everybody else in the chat so we're
pretty excited about that but
again there's just been so many things
going on in the world of street fighter
5 lately and it's been very exciting to
see
you know jeremy that's that's 100 true
right welcome everybody to the show i
just want to make sure you guys know
what you're watching this is the street
fighter 5
summer update no bathing suits needed
ladies and gentlemen
and just like vicious was talking about
we have done such a good job
and i say we i'm talking about capcom
they've done an amazing job
of steadily putting out these updates
showing us the ins and outs of what's
being developed right
showing us these new characters giving
us previews giving us a lot
of content and i'm going to tell you
right now i just want to thank capcom
for giving us this side of things
especially to the point where you get an
entire show to talk about some of these
updates and i'm going to tell you right
now this is a special one
because they have taken special care and
i mean special care because anybody that
works with me
and knows me knows that i hate spoilers
when i tell you the production was
making sure we don't know
anything about what about something
we're gonna be showing to you guys we
don't know anything
i think this is gonna be good um and
that's only for the fans that's not only
for the fans but some of the people
who've been playing street fighter for
years me personally
i cannot wait to see what we have in
store especially because street fighter
right now i mean you just came from
doing intel which is an olympic event
for street fighter 5 right
as well as the cpt still going strong
there's a lot of things you guys can do
in the world of street fighter and a lot
of ways that you guys can get included
on that action too
and trust me you're going to want to be
in tune about what we're about to reveal
because it's going to be a good one
yeah we've been hitting pretty much
across the globe when it comes to street
fighter 5 action in terms of tournaments
right and we've done so
even more so here at twitch gaming we
even showed off some of the emotes that
you guys have been consistently spamming
throughout the chat
steve why don't you let them know what
is going on
with these new global emotes
guys we talked about the world warrior
we talked about world competition we got
two new global emotes from the world of
street fighter added to the twitch
congressional congress of things to spam
in the chat we now have renew
we now have guile you guys i've already
seen it bro look at ryu's face
i've never seen this is actually
priceless i i cannot wait to express my
joy
through the ways of family man in
everybody's chat
now that these are released nobody is
safe from me spamming these emotes i'm
sorry but that's just how life goes
right this is gonna be it
this is gonna be it's gonna be a new a
new realm
of street fighter 5 uh emotes that i get
to spam out there and it's going to be
so so fun to watch and again just kind
of remind you guys all
over here right now you guys are just
spamming the heck out of it we
appreciate that just let you guys know
everything that goes on here at twitch
gaming is absolutely co-streamable so
just to kind of get you guys ready we
have
some of the biggest updates for street
fighter 5 and we want to make sure that
you
and your community are well tuned into
it so again be sure to co-stream this
event
as we break down what's to come now i
know steve we've been looking forward to
this for quite some time
what can we possibly expect
i possibly look i'ma tell you right now
the expectations are through the roof
right now
especially considering they've done such
a good job of putting a lot on the table
for us to digest
over the lifespan of street fighter
whether you're playing it casually
whether you're going to tournaments
there's a lot on the table so i'm glad
that they're making this cold stream
move
share it with the world share it with
your friends share it with your
community because this is about to be a
lot of updates coming down the pipeline
i know without a doubt again i'm i'm
just actually focused on the chat right
now i'm looking at how many people have
been
consistently spamming wii champ and
family man you already know that's going
to be
a big deal even outside of street
fighter i need to see it
that ryu chap is too funny when i first
saw it i was actually dying inside i was
like man i saw you guys even way before
the show started
it was actually pretty wild right they
were already in the chat like
spamming it right they were already in
the chat like yo you guys need to see
guile smiling i'm gonna tell you right
now i don't even think that dial smiles
in the game so that's hilarious and then
just a surprise facebook
i can't wait to keep some of these when
we go back and
watch some of these events some of these
amazing cpt events some of these amazing
street fighter events
make sure you use these brand new emotes
show the world your street fighter pride
drop the family man drop three youtube
and just share it you know i love the
the let's go and then you that's what
i'm talking about
spread it all all over the world man
and i know you guys have been very very
patiently waiting so without further ado
now that you guys
already know what the deal is here on
twitch gaming make sure to get that
co-streaming up get the email ready
because we do have
our first look at what's to come here
for the summer update
straight from the capcom developers
themselves let's see and take a look
at what we have for street fighter 5.
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
a
[Music]
[Music]
round one
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait
wait
[Music]
[Music]
is
foreign
bro i don't even care about being the
best in america
i'm the best in the world
we are here for the final event to see
who wins
street fighter league
we are excited to come back and play
it's gonna be the biggest showdown
one of these two teams will be crowned
nassar
against alpha threesome
if you stand in my way i will kill you
he's not ready for this though
this is only the beginning we're going
to week one
the stakes are significantly higher oh
my god
you're still alive oh my god
oh my god he's doing it for his team
right now
[Music]
[Music]
quickly
i dare you to find better street fighter
i
dare you
[Music]
steve oh what's happening
it's so good
[Music]
let's go let's go off
there's a lot to digest in that last
little group of things that we just saw
first off we got our first look
at oral and a deep deep breakdown
uh behind the scenes looks gets no
better than that first off
we got the intro to oro and we got match
footage
on top of that with a complicated
breakdown of how this character could
potentially work
and some previews to the power of
characters
not only that they segued into the
street fighter league
season three trailer you guys you are
you can't do that
man i need to talk i'm picking up the
phone
i'm calling twitch right now listen why
you gotta break it down like that why
are you gonna break it down like that
this is
this is actually wild let's talk about
let's talk about oil for a second let's
keep it let's keep it cool
so there are a lot of things that were
on our mind both steve and i i know for
sure there are fans of the series that
have been following
when they saw aura we were looking at
what kind of move list he's going to
have going into it
a lot of those questions were directly
answered
by the two uh matsumoto as well as
they were showing off everything that
oro had in the past and
reinventing it no that's 100
true right so the thing that street
fighter 5 has done beautifully if you
ask me is that they've taken so many
generational characters and added them
to street fighter 5 and the v system
does a very unique thing of showing how
these characters can be different and
still pay homage
to the games that they originally came
from in the street fighter series
oro is no different he still has
yakidama he still has the double jump
and he still has reminiscent combos of
his third strike iteration and i know
that's going to make a lot of people
happy
i just gotta say he goes to capcom just
like that right there
and just even seeing these guys play the
character in the street fighter 5
setting still displays some of those
dope callbacks to the character's
history overall right
even giving us back the spirit bomb on
top of it
a person that's the ex is the sickest
thing you were only able to do that if
you had max meter and if you do it for
like you use like multiple buttons right
but the fact that they allow you to have
multiple super arts from third strike
into one complete package
is probably the coolest thing it's
absolutely the coolest thing
i i personally like i said man i am you
know i'm a nostalgia person man
third strike is one of my favorite games
having these characters come back not
only just alex you know what i'm saying
we ain't got that trailer yet but not
only just alex
i love the fact that they're giving us
these characters and they have so much
rich history kind of built into the
gameplay
i just got to say man kudos to the team
for giving us this kind
this kind of character love as well as
just the dedication to the characters
having that gameplay alone really
answers a lot of the questions that we
had
lingering from the spring update right
being able to check out
what oro can do for a plethora of
situations right we're kind of looking
at the combo ability
we're looking at how he escapes from
certain options we're looking at the
mix-ups that he could potentially have
with that yagi-odama and the damage
output from tengu stone
that has been on my mind since we last
saw each other over at twitch gaming for
street fighter
5 and now that we've seen the full
capabilities or at least actually just a
sliver of it
it's been nothing but man like positive
vibes in my head i'm like okay
now we get to put the pieces together
now that we've seen gameplay footage of
oro we understand how to kind of
organize our game plan strategy as to
how we should play this character a
little bit and now i'm excited even more
when this character gets released
because you already know a lot of these
cats out in the twitterverse out and
social media in general
are well aware of how to make this
character as cheap as possible and just
from looking at the gameplay
he looks pretty good he looks pretty
good look i'm gonna tell you right now
you talking about the gameplay i want to
talk a little bit about that other
that other little snippet we saw for
street fighter league
season three it's getting real guys i'm
gonna tell you right now
we got a new character we got rolls we
got dan that's all gonna be added to the
collective roster
but that is gonna play a major major
role
in some of the characters we're gonna
see play for street fighter league
this season is actually going to be
ridiculous the teams were amazing you
guys saw a little bit of the rivalry
some
a little bit of the heated action that
happens on street fighter league
and me and vicious were a big part of
that man let me say shout outs to rob tv
uh brian f as well there's a lot of
people that have really put in
to show what street fighter 5 is about
and street fighter league is gonna be
something amazing man
shout outs to punk shout out to samurai
you got glimpses
of some of the action that's gonna
happen there and i'm gonna tell you
right now if you think we're high pier
it is a completely different world the
street fighter league you think you play
street fighter
you know nothing street fighter players
you watch
and tell me you're gonna find better
street fighter because i promise you
it's look i put it on the beads guys
i promise you you hear that that's the
solemn promise you're not gonna find
better street fighter than what you see
at street fighter league i'm just being
honest man i'm just telling you guys
what i know
what i've seen i instinctive i ain't
thinking with my own eyes i've seen it
but this is hey i've seen the reflection
in vicious head of some of the great
street fighter we've seen and i promise
you guys
please go watch street fighter league
it's the that's the thing here it's the
best bro
that's the thing about street fighter
league right you think i'm bald just
because of hereditary causes no it's
because of how stressful some of these
matches and how hype they can be
i've been pulling my hair out i look
like tasty steve before i got into
street fighter league that's how
it truly was to be real with you to be
absolutely real with you
but i gotta say that was just a little
bit of
what we have for you here in the summer
update we're actually moving quite
quickly i feel like is it time i think
it's time
we got ourselves another big
collaboration that we kind of talked
about
back in february it was announced during
capcom finals and i believe it was a
collaboration with a pretty big
game steve i would say an epic
game if you will we've already talked
about these crossovers we've already
seen a fortnight crossover earlier but i
believe these guys
are crossing paths once again let's take
a look at this new reveal
for the fortnite x street fighter 5
crossover
and you see it right there cammy and
guile
included into the realm of fortnite i
can't wait to see these two
join up in the battle bus and flash kick
everybody off of it to be quite honest
with you
no that's definitely true that's
definitely true first off i got to
commend them for putting the stubble on
my man's gal's face
he's seen a few things it's only right
and seeing some things also the cami
redesign is actually really dope one of
the things i really like about the
fortnite collabs is the fact that they
redesigned some of these characters to
fit the world but they still hold their
iconic outfits
and sometimes i get a nice little twist
on the redesign so i said i gotta say
shout outs to everybody who plays
fortnite as well as these crossovers
that's continuing to happen because
personally i think it's really really
cool
and oh yo they got that i didn't see
this coming yo yo the battle bus is in
the back of the air force stage
yo that's a sick this actually said i
get the kind of spike you went to town
all the way down to tomato town oh and
the flash kick off the battle bus that's
what i'm saying steve
that's what i was waiting for so
did you hear that tell me you heard they
even got the voice goods too
yo they got the actual voice this is
godlike that's
actually god like originally
oh my god so not only are they giving us
these outfits these collabs but they're
giving us dope characters
that paying homage to the game that they
come from they're giving us the
voiceovers as well
gail and cammy will be available in
fortnight shop starting
august 7th at 8pm eastern time both
characters come with a chance to unlock
even more gear i promise you just like
the world of street fighter you're going
to get a lot of outfits
to go on with these characters but the
design of these characters being
incorporated into class fortnight is
gonna be ridiculous i mean i feel like
it's only right
that they put these skins in street
fighter v i'm just gonna leave it there
but you're gonna see that that version
of the fatigues yeah
it makes absolutely perfect sense to be
honest with you is that a pair of
handcuffs on his waist that's like the
utility belt
that's he's always a police officer
right there all the old people know
that's like he used to put you in
handcuffs
but they put it in fortnite so you guys
are getting a little extra
you guys are getting a little extra on
the side of paying homage to these
characters
making them look cool as well as fitting
in i mean even to have them on this
iconic stage
showing you some of the things that they
can do at fortnight is one of the
coolest things you can have
they have a bunch of extra stuff too
they got the borealis back uh backer
back bling
uh kind of reminiscent of the cami stage
right there's so many things that they
actually
can put on these characters like the
gliders and whatnot cami's delta red
bully blade pickaxe that is hard to say
but i'll tell you what that looks
actually pretty hype so there's gonna be
so many things
to to collect for these two characters
right in fact
we do have even more coming in for
fortnight
uh in august fifth i do believe candy
cup is actually happening to celebrate
the arrival of both
kyle and cammy you can participate in
the candy cup to win some of that gear
and um pretty much increase your
collection right any team that earns at
least 10 points
in this event will also receive the
round two
loading screen so all the exclusive
stuff that you can find in the shop
you could actually participate in this
cami cup and win them instead
giving you that street fighter feel that
tournament feel
in fortnight so make sure you guys join
candy cup
august 5th you want some extra loot you
want a cool round two loading screen
all you got to do is get eight points
but to get eight points you guys have to
enter
the cami cup wow i don't think i've ever
even seen that look at this cool stuff
i'm gonna tell you right now fortnite
you guys do such a good job with the
splash screens and the integration
shout out to capcom for making this even
possible because i'm gonna tell you
right now there's a lot of love
that's being held in there and that is
that round
two loading screen that we have for you
guys a lot of little aesthetic guys
is some of the dopest things you can ask
for when it comes to these collabs
these crossovers i'm glad that these
guys are continuing to work together
because like i said
fortnite is one of those games that
everybody's playing we already got ryu
we already got chun li
and now uh cammy and gail and you guys
can get them yourself that's gonna be
august the 7th
8pm eastern time they should be in the
shop tweet it out once you get it man
let capcom
let epic let the fortnite world know
that you guys got yourself some gal and
some cammy and your fortnight
now with that being said let's go too we
want to see all of that as well make
sure to tag us at all the photos that
you get all the screenshots you get from
playing
in fortnite because it's a whole entire
world of fair right you got
real the world warrior you got interpol
with chun li
you got the us air force and guy delta
red with cabbie it's actually pretty
wild to see this collaboration
no i think it's one of the coolest man
uh these continued collapse is one of
the reasons that i feel like
capcom has been on the up man and
looking at like devil may cry and
all these other games they've come out
with this is just a part of it man i
love that we get to see street fighter
in a lot more things other than just
street fighter so this is really really
cool but
speaking of we're gonna dive a little
deeper man we still have more for you
guys even more so to the fact
we have a behind the scenes look once
again
for the audio director yasuyuki
sugino will be giving us a little behind
the scenes look and he is the new audio
director starting on season 5
of street fighter 5 and personally i'm
such
a big fan um working on devil may cry 3
one of my favorite games ever has worked
on the resident evil series
has also worked on the monster hunters
so this
is a actually a pretty cool thing to see
the legacy that this guy has and will be
bringing
is going to be really cool so let's take
a look at what the new audio director
will be giving us
in the street fighter 5.
fighter 5 season 5
foreign
[Music]
foreign
character
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yes
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
if i go too far please forgive me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
is it
[Music]
fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
make your move i'm sorry show me a real
attack
um
[Applause]
[Music]
my
there's so much to digest
they are really dumping it on man we got
to start from the top though
we got to start from the top though i
know you guys want to talk about that
accuracy
let's talk about yasuke sugino actually
giving us the sound bites the breakdown
of how they create the sound effects
first off i want to say next time you
need some help doing this so geno sun
let me know i'll come in
we can make these sound effects together
i have no problem helping out but like i
said a legendary
a legendary audio director who's worked
on a mini series before is devil may cry
resident evil monster hunter mega man
this isn't his first street fighter
i already know so across the board
there's so many games so suji sign i
just want to say thank you for
everything and welcome to the team even
if you have done a little work before
i like the fact that you're majorly
involved and these sound effects are
there to prove it
speaking of sound effects mr vicious we
got some very
complicated sound effects when we got
the intro to accuracy
because i know that i'm going to play
vicious i was like ah crap
because he was like this is the
character back i'm like why would you do
this and i'm gonna tell you guys this
character
the brother is right there and the fact
on the street the character that i
played
the character that i played in rivals a
lot
edge within the background so i'm
telling you right now
the stage the character the way the
character plays vicious talk to us a
little bit about what we saw
gameplay-wise when it comes to a camera
because this is definitely your kind of
character if you ask me
so we saw a little bit of the gameplay
footage from the spring update but we
saw we've seen so much more right just
off the cusp
we're seeing how she is as a character
aesthetically staying true to the roots
to project justice or rival schools in
general
and for the most part i was kind of
looking at it last night i'm like all
right
what are the kind of moves that she has
and thankfully shuhei and nakayama
they both actually knocked out of the
park explaining how close to the series
she was actually
or she actually is in terms of the
movement in terms of how she actually
does her strikes
everything even her special moves right
one of the things off the bat that i
yelled at tcc for
was her walk speed her walk speed is
actually
immaculate when you take a look at
competitive street fighter 5
you kind of figure these things out like
all right well walk speed can actually
be pretty dangerous because they have an
even better time
going across the stage being able to
whiff punish you apply even more
pressure
and ocular feels like that complete
package she has a fireball she has an
uppercut she has normals that reach
pretty well
everything i feel like she is going to
be the character to look out for
and the fact that they actually dropped
the date of august 16th
get our hands on it that's actually
pretty wild everything that you've seen
here
is reminiscent of rival schools right
you even saw the synchronous attack
towards the end with the critical art
you've seen the air combo mechanics and
even some of the graphics they included
with accurate special moves it's going
to be
i feel like a perfect love letter to the
previous series
here into street fighter 5. look i know
you were talking like about like the
mechanics and how she works first off i
loved how flushed out this character is
has
a very unique play style but i want to
touch back on the fact what you were
talking about
this character has a lot of things that
are missed from the original series that
this character comes from right
the air combos which are very unique to
rival schools
the way that they work very unique to
rival schools the fact that she gets to
call out another character from the
series her brother daigo
to come down and help you and force that
mix up as well and even the reminiscence
of when she activates her v-trigger or
her ca
it looks very much like aesthetically
how it looked in the games of rival
schools so once again a love letter like
you said
to these classic franchises as well as
the fact that now that these universes
are one you can get all kind of
unbelievable crossovers
not only that look cool but they pay
homage to these characters in such a
cool way
and i think fans new and old old like
myself
knew like some of you people out there
will grant i mean guaranteed will enjoy
this character i can see it already
yeah we were literally yelling pretty
much at the top of our lungs watching
all the kind of footage that transpired
with ocular right we were talking about
the different kinds of pressure she has
her options for damage especially
through v
trigger and some of the versatility
behind this v-trigger right here with
v-trigger one being able to
call daigo and get your left right
mix-ups going high-low mix-ups going
everything that she has i feel like is
perfect for
street fighter 5 to be a top contender
yeah this character really looks like
she kind of changes the way you're going
to play neutral you talked about her
walk speed and how strong it could be
normals look very strong as well her
norm the way her normals are looking it
looks like she's going to be able to
lock you down with that walk speed on
top of the fact that she has this
projectile right she has this projectile
that can actually bounce you off the
wall if you use the ex she can use it in
the air as well
and i feel like she's going to fit right
in with the cast so far
um you talked about her you having that
kind of gennady gin like activation
right
and it looks like just like they were
talking about nakayama-san was talking
about
you can confirm some of these combos
from standing as well as crouching right
you have those universal options but
you're going to be able to confirm and
maximize
optimize some of your options when it
comes to some of these straight hits
which i
really like and it brings a lot of
uniqueness to the character means you
got to pay attention and some of the
players out there that will be playing
this character
i guarantee you they're going to take
full advantage of this and that's kind
of where street fighter 5
is headed right i feel like we've gotten
more and more complicated characters
that's the further we got in the series
as well as just the fact that these
characters are brand new to the first
showing in street fighter does
so much for the calling so that's a lot
to digest right
i mean tsuji san actually showed us how
the sound was made then we went in
giving us the sound they gave us the
breakdown of how these sounds were
incorporated
right into the seamless segue of showing
us how akira is going to be
played and personally i cannot wait they
gave us the date
august the 16th you guys will be able to
download and play this character
yourselves
they gave us a look at all the outfits
and of course reveal there's one
more character remaining but you guys
already have a lot on your plate we've
dropped so much
for you guys to digest and there's still
more i mean personally right
i cannot wait i cannot wait to give my
tribe these characters because as you
both know i mean as you know
twitch chat and vicious you already know
we gotta de-dive on these characters i'm
pretty sure i'm gonna be pretty upset
playing vicious with akira already it's
gonna be fine because you get to listen
to all the
new tracks that come out from cap jam
and the sound department just in general
right we've seen
the kind of behind the scenes look
actually this was one of the more hype
parts
that we were tuned into because not
every day do we get to see
developers show us what goes into
uh making these kind of efforts for the
games right the sound effects
the music as well the fact that they
have a full-on capcom employee
band to show you what's good with their
new
newly orchestrated like remixes of these
songs
that's actually pretty ridiculous like
that's a lot of a lot of things that
they're showing
to kind of give you the fans um
something to look forward to right
all their hard work and everything that
they've put into um
not even just like the gameplay and the
aesthetics but even the sound direction
and even
what they have with the songs overall
it's been super sick to watch i didn't
even think
you know i would ever see something like
that from publishers ever
but the fact that they have a full-on
band as well i know steve was going
nuts over this so this is one of the
things i've actually i told capcom staff
about this myself
the fact that they went the extra route
and gave us that extra extra
dope theme that live performance of the
new retooled
dan theme and they continue to do this
right they're retooling a lot of the
themes but this dan theme
actually hit home the fact that they
said that there's a band of
capcom cup employee capcom capcom
employees
that actually are in a band that perform
these songs to make them more
danceable says a lot personally you know
i'm a fan of all the kind of aesthetic
nuances that they put in these games
i love music i love the sound design i
love the sound direction
the fact that this is so in tune and
they have a good plan they have an idea
of how they want this game to sound
does so much for what we get from street
fighter 5 man once again man
susie-san as well as everybody else at
capcom thank you guys so much because
personally i love this kind of intel i
love you guys sharing this with us
and the world out there at large loves
when you guys do this man you guys give
a lot of hope to the people that
indulge in this game who like this game
who like the sound design of this game
so we appreciate that and i like how
they kind of
give it back to uh shuhei-san to give us
a little bit more extra this is
something we did not
see coming the tournament mode coming
into street fighter 5 is
such a good thing because now everybody
in their communities whether it's a dojo
people on discord people in social media
in general can now organize these
tournaments to figure out who is
actually the best of the best
whether it be from their direct region
or they can invite players
and they also had that team mode aspect
tasty steve and i were like yo
we're definitely hopping on to some team
fights we got to make sure
that we let let the world know what the
commentators are all about but no
honestly the
the tournament mode is something you
know being redone
was something that was kind of lacking
in the beginning we wanted to see what
was going to come out of it even more
and shuhei and nakayama-san
delivered with this announcement
look the tournament mode is something
that a lot of people look forward to
vicious said seriously while we were
watching he's like yo we could actually
stream this
and like we can all play and it looks
like it ties into that dojo system that
is active in street fighter 5 right now
right and they give you the brackets
they give you a cool overlay and i got
to tell you right now i was already a
fan of how you know championship edition
you know showed itself right the way
that they you know displayed it the
versus screen the character select
screen
this adds even more to it all the
aesthetic designs all the little teasers
that's given and it goes seamlessly into
the arcade mode when it comes to
presentation
as well as just making it an enjoyable
thing to look at and incorporating dojos
not only on the team side but having
that single player tournament aspect
is something that's really cool
especially with the online incorporation
i feel like you know you guys can hold
tournaments out of your house at this
point
and have your best friends from around
the neighborhood come and play and i'm
sure that was what they were thinking
about so in
all honesty man once again this is
another thing done expertly
integrating something like this into a
game like street fighter 5 that's you
know
built for people who like to get it to
their competitors they like to fight in
the digital world
give them those online tournaments give
them the pizzazz of it as well as you
know give them that presentation that's
already in the game
kudos once again to capcom for making
this happen man i can't wait
to get my hands on myself and start
having tournaments with some of my
friends around the country
and potentially around the world you get
to show off as a group as well i really
want to implement that kind of group
three on three
tournament mode style and pretty much
see you know we can hold
there's so many possibilities around it
right you can hold so many kind of uh
events for different communities whether
it's like uh whether it's like rookies
or we have seasoned veterans or people
that just
love the game of street fighter 5
implementing this mode and kind of
rehashing it
in this way i feel like is a great step
forward into engaging with a lot of the
different kinds of communities out there
for street fighter v
and again it's just gonna be even better
we'll get to see the community
rise up above the occasion and get
better they get to play more matches
with each other
get more match exposure and figure out
some of these
matchups and speaking of matchups we
actually have another one for you
up on the deck with something very
exclusive
well look guys we gave you guys the
breakdown right we gave you guys the
breakdown
nakayama-san that gave us the breakdown
of oro they gave us the breakdown
of akira what happens when these two
characters actually meet up in a match
of street fighter 5 championship edition
i know
vicious wants to know i want to know you
want to know
so let's take a look some exclusive
match footage
we have very first for your eyes only
don't adjust them get the sleep out
this is oral versus akira street fighter
5 let's check it out
this is going to be pretty wild this is
happening live before our very eyes by
the way this is our first time seeing it
first time first
time seeing it and we have the honor of
being able to commentate
how it's gonna go down so let's get
started all over again we're seeing the
set one to one with oro and we're seeing
v skill two and v trigger one from the
side of ocular
now you already see akira controlling
the range with that low four just to
start off and has three different angles
for that command that that command she
can anti-area with it but using a normal
this time around
projectile and that is going to do a lot
of the nice little chunk of chip damage
she has an ex option as well
gets the crush counter as well no not
making anything of it you saw the media
blitz come out
four medium punches coming out from oro
into trigger activation but can he make
anything of it
the big sweep for the punish against
sauro
i really want to see wake up ex dragon
punching the follow-up between it you're
going to step on her with no shoes on
the disrespect making sure the turkey
you see the kind of dwindling uh the
dwindling down of the v-trigger or was
looking for any confirm into the ex
command grab
combo oh you guys what's the mixer
nissan you see you hear her call it out
in japanese nissan
come help me was actually pretty sick
and that's right
that was pretty much a check checkmate
scenario i feel like with the lines
going down there was still full critical
art on deck i feel like akira could have
spent it as well just in case for the
chip damage big jumping round off
to catch him again
are you kidding me yeah that was
actually pretty cheap didn't get
anything big from a nice tech here
that standing heavy kick if you notice
orals dash is very reminiscent of the
third strike jump the third strike game
is really fast low to the ground and you
can see him crouch and get low
oh man that heavy kick is so far out
there forward thrown out
keeps the corner dash up i want to see
some of these overhead
options that oro has now in street
fighter 5
ex fireball just to keep the pressure
overhand overhead respect it
and we haven't seen any of like the
yamadama setups yet but we're going to
see at least
try an attempted side switch there from
ocular trying to keep the pressure
here's an activation for the trigger
you're going to see a lot of damage
take out the trash on the ground
i like that up angle fireball not a lot
of characters in this game have the
control fireball and now this character
actually has two
options right you're gonna get two
fireballs on the screen at one time with
oral
just facing really strong right now
there's a viewer not gonna work out
oh looks like the stanley kick right
there from oro just to check the range
maybe
checking a dash a possible throw coming
from akira but that's one round a piece
and the turtle still holds prominence my
man is holding it with one hand a lot of
people don't know this but oral
when was first introduced a lot of
people thought the character had one arm
but this is an earlier version of the
character as in story wise
so using both hands in the sense of like
i'm that's how strong i am oro is so
strong
that in other games he only uses one
hand but this time steal you
one hand and supporting the turtle on
top of it yeah
one of the things i'm looking for also
in this matchup is how akira kind of
traverses past
any sort of fireballs but you could see
the damage output she has when she locks
you in the corner right it kind of
reminiscent of ken but this is what i
wanted to see yeah
switch off the command grab no anti-air
though once again using that v scale we
talked about this that v-trigger excuse
me just to keep the pressure going
and we saw in the video that they could
be used to press the block pressure as
well just go forward
oh that was a chunk oh
nice get out of the conversion
yeah that beat shift was really smart at
that range we've noticed that orwell has
some pretty strong normals that light
kick stopped the oppression from last
time
and the long distance ex that was crazy
that hit so
far away didn't give you the wall bounce
but actually gave you the knock down
and that's gonna be that akira takes it
over oro
and what a display what a display
of these characters once again i could
take this back to the top of the show
and i was talking about what capcom has
done
was revealing some of these characters
giving matches where you see
some of the people play some of the new
v skills some of the new v
triggers gives you a nice little peek at
what these characters can do
not only for you guys at home but at a
high level tournament side because it's
gonna be
completely different when some of these
players get their hands on it we saw the
street fighter league we're gonna see it
in tournaments and we're gonna see it
from you guys at home
this character is definitely gonna be
fun to play has a lot of throwbacks to
like i said from the third strike
iteration of itself
i mean and then you look at akira who is
virtually a new character incorporated
into the street fighter 5 engine
a bunch of unique moves as well as
aesthetic pleasures for
anybody who's played those games as well
as anybody new to
rival schools and street fighter 5 man i
personally i can't wait for these
characters to drop
uh august 16th can't come soon enough i
can't wait to play
you're damn right and you were talking
about some of the aesthetic pleasures
right in fact twitch gaming has teamed
up with capcom
to deliver that even more physically
right we actually have
some pretty sweet merchandise coming
your way in regards to
our special celebration here for the
summer update we do have our t-shirts
exclusively with twitch gaming we do
have oro as well as acura
to show off to you guys in fact we've
seen it oh boy
i think it might have circulated on
twitter i think twitch put it up this
morning
but take a look at some of the designs
we have for
this summer update for these two
characters look man i'm gonna tell you
guys right now i already got like a few
twitch hoodies a few twitch sweaters in
my closet
i can tell you right now both of these
shirts can go nicely along with them
akira
riding the motorcycle that she comes
into the match on of course with that
six goal logo on the back
and of course oro one of the strongest
people in the street fighter universe i
love
the kind of vaporware so cool the
technicolor color of oral right here on
the shirt you can see the turtles on the
sling leave
right so excited to see twitch on the
other one make sure you guys get your
very own to enter for a chance to win
all you have to do is spend 10 channel
points you can earn 10 channel points by
watching the show for five minutes on
the twitch
uh tv uh the twitch gaming channel or
you can earn 300 channel points
immediately by following
slash twitch gaming uh the contest is
available for
only u.s residents i apologize but for
those who are
do qualify you guys can get your chance
to win your very own
oral or akira shirt i personally i would
like to both
if i had to get one give me the oro if
you want to be nice
you send me the akira
right now i'm gonna wear that on every
stream i'll tell you what i actually
entered the giveaway as well i don't
know if you did steve but check out the
chat be sure to use those points
again you guys have been watching for
quite some time now use it for this
giveaway for your chance at these
exclusive t-shirts
when these characters are out this is
going to be
so sick when they release in august 16th
man i personally think that we've had so
much news today man there's been
so much news i mean we got to look at
behind the scenes not only on the
development side but on some of the
things they've been doing we got
banned we got brand new music we they
talked to us about the development side
of things they gave us a character
display
for both of them we got a brand new
collab with fortnite we got a new
t-shirt
street fighter league synthetic we got
so much for you guys
but i'm pretty sure that should be it
you guys have had enough you've been
entertained
i feel like we should just let them know
we can just cut the stream here and
people will be happy right no no
no no no no wait a minute no wait a
minute i made sure to call mr and mrs
twitch at their offices and i'm like no
i need you to release some extra footage
we've waited so long
for this update you think we're gonna
end it here heck
no i'll tell you what right now let's go
exclusive footage for you let go
take a look at how we round out this
summer update for street fighter 5
champion edition roll it
up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
what and he was like i'm never gonna
listen to anyone i was like talk to me
even his v-trigger activation
oh my god these are the kind of things
that i like to see
you're going to give me a character let
him pop off and on top of that he's full
that man got the chest tattoo he's got
this all i got to show you he's got the
he's got the undercut as well my man is
a part of the current times
as well as he just
[Music]
y'all show me that forward throw real
quick i gotta see the four that's gotta
be
over here that's gotta be over here bro
this like i'm telling you right now no
exaggeration
this character
that was so sick oh my god your chat yo
checks
yeah okay okay okay okay this character
is actually sick
this character is actually sick please
chat let me know how you guys feel make
some noise in the chat if you're liking
luke
i can see your comments on the screen my
man alex blow says
i really love them as you should
dropping the new global e-boats on top
of it
luke joins the roster of street fighter
5
the last character in the roster will be
none
other than luke a brand new character
for the world of street fighter 5 bro
and i'ma tell you right now
i know everybody's going to try this
character at least once he looks way too
cool
to left to be left undiscovered untapped
and
on top of that like i feel like it makes
a complete balance we got a returning
character
we got a new character to the series
coming from another game
and now to head things off we have a
brand
new character character i'm super
interested to see what this character's
gonna bring to the table
obviously they thought this through full
screen it looks like projectiles as well
uh looks like he has an overhead and
just the design aesthetically
i'm super interested in i know this is
gonna get a lot of play
and just jeremy what do you think man
what are your so
aesthetically he looks like a badass i'm
gonna tell you right now
look at the combo sequence that he has
it looks like he has so much damage on
the table
and also i feel like he's gonna be kind
of similar to ed like he's got a lot of
target combo stuff too right so it's
gonna be
very easy to kind of execute but at the
same time it's like we have no idea
november cannot come soon enough the way
that he finessed ryu
from one part of the screen to the other
that entire look
gave me chills and steve and i were
going through the roof
yeah my voice is gonna be gone pretty
pretty soon right
but no luke is looking like a great
addition to street fighter look at that
man like
come on
he's swinging with the most emotion
we've seen in like street fighter 5
characters or just street fighter
characters in general right
we've seen traditional movement when it
comes to street fighter characters this
one i feel like has the most emotions
when you're looking at how much he's
like swinging through somebody he's not
looking at you
he's swinging through you right yeah
that's a huge difference you can see the
impact from the design alone
i can't wait i cannot wait till november
comes through i gotta say
matsumoto hey takayuki nakayama you guys
are
ridiculous at what you do and you guys
are so amazing for even
giving us this street for the fifth
character
i i once again man i have to commend
them for first off
being a lot more public with what they
plan to do with the game it is done
so much for how people enjoy the game
and not only on the side of you know
balance and whatnot et cetera et cetera
but looking
at deeper into these characters looking
deeper into the development process of
the game
and then with the icing on the cake
sending you guys home
with something beautiful to think about
something to dream about when november
hits you get that last character
added to the roster and personally just
i'm having so much fun having so much
fun
exploring street fighter 5 looking at
these characters how they're going to
develop i mean not only did we get
another new character to think about but
august the 16th we're gonna get two
brand new characters with akira and oral
and you still have one more before the
end of everything before the end of the
year november you get another character
capcom
you guys have done a great job i can't
wait to play more street fighter 5.
i gotta say man overall with everything
that's been put on the table now and how
open capcom has been
i've been pretty overwhelmed i was very
anxious to see this
i wanted to see how they were going to
deliver it considering how it happened
in the spring update
i will say that the spring or the summer
update
has been it answered so many questions
it is
so much that they publicly put out there
and showing and progressing all of their
hard work
for everybody today and i'm so thankful
that we got to experience it not only
with you steve
not only here at twitch gaming but with
you guys at home as well steve i got to
ask you as well how did you feel overall
with everything that was put up here for
the summer update i can't even stress it
enough man like like i said each one of
these
updates have gotten better and better
when it comes to the delivery of
information
what they've shown us and even just
seeing the faces of some of the people
that work on the game and how they work
on the game
these are things that i love to see
coming from especially not only just any
development
but a game that i play so much right
this is the kind of intel you want about
these games not only with the characters
not only with the you know the building
up and the development of these games
but just with the community this kind of
community interaction takes us a long
way when it comes to fighting games
because you get a feel for what these
companies what these players
what the scene wants from these games
and i feel like once again
capcom has done it capcom has done an
amazing job so far i can't wait for luke
i know you can't wait for a cara i can't
wait for
i can't wait for any of the new things
that have coming out but with with that
being said guys
vicious you make sure you tell these
people where to follow you the things
that you do what you talk about talk to
us real quick before we get out of here
you can see it down below right you see
vicious fgc that's going to be my twitch
for the most part and everything on
social media that's going to be all
street fighter and fighting game related
to be quite honest with you
when these characters drop best believe
both steve and myself are going to be
streaming the heck out of it to give you
everything that you need to know in
terms of how the character operates
what to expect with their gameplay as
well as how to go above and beyond to
become a competitive player with some of
these characters again vicious ftc is
how you can find me on twitch and you
can find my boy tasty underscore steve
over on twitch
showcasing as many fighting games as
possible and best believe you know
what's going to be street fighter 5
when it comes to this new update right
steve look i'm telling you right now i
play
fighting games religiously so you know
you're going to be able to tune into
twitch.tv slash tasty underscore steve
or some street fighter action man all
honesty i just love
being a part of the scene i love being
involved with these kind of projects
because it gives a lot to the people
that i heard that love these games and
like i said at tasty underscore steve on
everything
that's instagram that's twitch that's
twitter you name it
you find me come show some love and as
always guys
i appreciate being here i appreciate my
bro vicious as well so look guys i'm
gonna break it down one more time
don't forget use those channel points to
get that shirt and of course august the
16th is when we get two
brand new characters added to the world
of street fighter and then in november
we still got luke with that being said
ladies and gentlemen i need you to do me
one big favor
always make some noise you guys be well
peace
i know you got really excited about that
one steve and i will tell you something
real quick
you guys do not want to miss everything
else that happens over on twitch gaming
if you guys haven't done so already
hit that follow button because we have
so many shows make sure to hit that
follow because we have a ton of shows
with twitch gaming
with hive mind going on every wednesday
at 10 a.m to pacific standard time
and the weekly every thursday 11 pacific
time so
many more of that information coming out
very very
soon again you want to catch those two
shows hive minor wednesday 10 a.m
the weekly every thursday 11 a.m be sure
to hit that follow button
now without further ado we appreciate
you guys hanging out with us for
the street fighter 5 summer update we'll
see you guys
next time
hmm